for this quiz you're gonna be putting
your name and your role to the top of
your resume using the same technique
James just used you'll start by
replacing percent data percent an HTML
header name and HTML header role with
your name and your role in this case the
role is the type of job you're looking
for so for me I would have web developer
you can find the strings HTML header
name and HTML had a role within helper
j/s once you're done you will either
append or prepend
the formatted name and formatted role to
the page header now append add something
to the end of HTML while prepend adds
something to the beginning of HTML for
this quiz you might need to experiment
with append and prepend to get a feel
for both of them once you see your name
and role appear on the page correctly
check this box and when you do it right
your resume should look something like
this